[Music]
kermit doing shakira yeah
um miss piggy are you sir that your tits
are smiling
oh man okay let's talk about dating
let's talk about dating when we're
really young
drunk oh this what what is that oh
this is what are you doing a bottle of
cognac sent to me by some uh cambodians
cambodian cognac i guess it's cambodian
conan yeah yeah golden what
a what is like a uh temple wow yeah like
ink or what encore watching
all right wait so wait what does that
have to do with eating
because drink on dates no but i want to
talk about dating
when you are when you're 12 years old
i went on a date you did oh yeah you go
movie theater
did you stay after dark i think so girl
were you guys still together after dark
we were it was her sister was there with
her boyfriend
and then um we were sitting kind of
close to each other and we were making
out the whole movie and she gave me a
hickey and i
and i rubbed her vaginas
[Laughter]
she was 13. wow so she knew wait what
what's 12 seventh grade sixth grade
seventh grade
yeah around that time that was the first
time yeah
wow wait but were you guys pants on were
you guys on this date
after after sunset
uh by the time we left the theater was
dark why are you so focused on dusk and
dawn
because if you were in indonesia
and you were all still on this date
after
dusk you would have been forced to marry
that girl
what because it's like a werewolf
marriage
is this for anybody or only if you're 12
no if you're 12 and a half are safe
no so there's a story about this
15 year old boy and a 12 year old girl
in indonesia
that they were forced to get married
after breaking a local custom that
forbids dating
after sunset what's the difference
uh apparently there's just this custom
that you should not be
in each other's dating presence because
once it hits nighttime it's a
sin now you're with her you have to be
committed for life now
okay lunch dates are like we're just
getting coffee getting to know each
other
but night dates is let's put on the red
lipstick and [ __ ]
we get married oh this couple here
they had only been on four dates days of
dating like they only went on four dates
and so after this one night so this the
boy brought his girlfriend home after 7
30 p.m
and is home safe is it like are you
say [ __ ] it boys that makes it even
worse
worse because they're together you
should not be together but what about
the parents though
so it's actually the girls parents that
are forced this marriage oh cause she's
like
oh she's tainted now she can't come back
home
she's like you have her you keep her guy
really rich the boyfriend's parents were
like
no come on like what the [ __ ] take your
daughter home can we just like ignore
this one time like this is insane i
don't want my 15 year old son marrying
your 12 year old daughter just because
they were on a date
and after sunset is a guy really rich i
don't know
see that's that's you're thinking asian
you're thinking like an indonesian man
yeah so this is like a specific part of
indonesia yes
okay okay it's a specific part like with
the specific village
that they they honor that custom or at
least the girls parents
honor that custom to the point where
they did end up getting married oh my
god
married whoa what blows my mind though
is that
okay with the rule like this you expect
them to be conservative
but then you don't expect conservative
families letting their 12 year old go on
dates
maybe she snuck out oh
true i don't know i don't know the
circumstances behind that but
they were uh they did have
this like sort of ceremony that were
it was witnessed by dozens of relatives
and neighbors and so that footage of
the the wedding was shared on
indonesian social media and it just
sparked
a debate about child marriage and like
why should look all sad
[ __ ] now they can after they could
is it illegal for kids to [ __ ]
i don't know because it's illegal for an
adult to [ __ ] a kid
yeah but it's a is it illegal no i think
two underage kids can legally have sex
with each other
indonesia are here oh i'm sorry because
what i'm thinking about is
okay so like what we're imagining is
like high school sex which is like
normal right yeah but to me 12 is
borderline so like that's like a high
school
guy [ __ ] a junior high kid which is
kind of weird but then like what if it
gets even
weirder and it's like a fifth grader
[ __ ] a high school kid
oh like is that illegal yeah that's
weird the way that i'm doing it is
um i know in a lot of places the minute
you're
married you're in a different class
you're an adult so now it's a husband
and wife [ __ ] and it's not
it's irrelevant of age it's the husband
and wife are [ __ ] and that's building
a family yeah because
you're now married or whatever legal
minimum age for marriage
yes so in indonesia they change their
marriage laws and raise the minimum age
for girls from 16 to 19.
but parents can still ask for
dispensation on the grounds
oh you can't marry till you're 19 there
that's awesome
yeah unless your parents are like
intervene
um but so for this specific marriage
here that we're talking about this 15
year old this 12 year old
so they did have like uh that ceremony
and all
but the wedding did not receive approval
from the religious affairs office yes
which legally sanctions marriages in
indonesia so
technically they're not legally married
but everyone
and especially their parents they're
like no they're married everyone's
married so that village is like [ __ ]
your law
right they're married yeah but it's not
legally recognized
not legally recognized yeah so
that's that's actually um older than
america i think amer well
it depends on the state but some states
you don't have to be 18
to actually get 19 right yeah really
that's what that's weird
so like it's it's a weird law where it's
like
you're you can't get married under age
but also it's it's still illegal
if you date somebody over age or like if
you have sex with it's so [ __ ] weird
like maybe it's like you can get married
underage with your
parents like consent right isn't that it
like you need like your parents right
here in the u.s yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then well same in indonesia
with your parents
we like asking hey or telling
whoever needs to know like hey i approve
of this marriage mary legally marielle i
remember for like
some cultures and arranged marriages
right like you'll
technically choose who your husband or
wife is going to be
like at an early ass age but they don't
get married until like later later on
so it's like yeah that's the boy you're
gonna marry okay and then like
fast forward to like i don't know like
high school age or whatever
it's crazy that arranged marriages are
like still a thing
like it's crazy thing because you grow
up and you hear about it and you think
it's like some really like
really old school foreign [ __ ] and then
to know that it's like pretty still
i remember hearing i don't know how
accurate this is but i remember hearing
a statistic where
arranged marriages tend to be more
successful
because they can't leave yeah my
my grandma my grandma wasn't arranged
huh because you spend your whole life
expecting it
that you're kind of well yeah because i
think you go in with the mindset of the
agreement
yeah like you have to make this work
yeah yeah like married at first sight
you know you guys watch me on the first
sight the reality show oh it's basically
an arranged marriage so it's like is it
like 90 day fiance
if you like 90 day fiance you'll enjoy
merida for a second
equally cringe but in a different way i
gotta see it i'm married at first sight
it's people who are like i'm sick of
being single i'm like 28 whatever
what yeah it's [ __ ] like that even
younger people being singles people even
younger
right but anyways people that sign up
are like i'm sick of being single i want
to settle down already and they trust
a group of relationship experts to pair
them with somebody else and then they
don't meet this person until literally
they're at the altar and then they say
so they have to say i do they can't be
like man what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's so scary so they
commit to this
they say i do that it's so long well so
then i think it's like a
an uh like a seven week eight week
period where they
move in together like they go on a
honeymoon
they get to know each other [ __ ]
immediately they can some of them do
some of them [ __ ] the first night some
of them don't [ __ ] at all
and then at the end of like eight weeks
they decide okay are we gonna get
divorced or we're gonna stay married you
know but it's real so it's all legal
wedding yeah yeah it's an option like
it's like it's any
marriage you know you can get divorced
if you want but it's like an actual
legal marriage and they get married they
move in together
and um sometimes they [ __ ] like there
are couples that are still together to
this day like after years of it
and then um yeah some that are just like
train wrecks which are great which you'd
love
that's an arranged marriage then yeah
married at first sight on lifetime
i like the blind one the one where
everyone's in a room that's
that if i had to pick a style of how i
was gonna have to get married if
i was in a different life then i would
want to do with that what's that
what is it called blind love is blind
love is blind that one
so basically they have um they put you
in they put the guys and the girls
in separate rooms and the only way you
guys can connect is
via just through a wall and you're just
asking questions so you don't see what
they look like
they both dry hump the wall there's just
holes in the wall
you dig and see if they match yeah
that's the only way
that's nice yeah damn that's a big
you are a thirsty man this is like an
arranged marriage
it's like i'm forcing myself to make i
would normally never drink this much
water but now that i'm like
i have to this is here in front of my
face i have to make it work
sometimes the choice or having the
choice of
not having to do something does backfire
mm-hmm
you know like you know that's why like
when you go like skydiving or bungee
jumping or whatever they always go on
the count of three they don't give a
[ __ ]
wait wait wait they're just pushing
around that's why they they jump on two
they go one two that's when they jump
yeah i know that now
yeah yeah because they don't want
[ __ ]
y'all for sure yeah no choices that's
why they make you do this because then
you could like yeah you just have to
make it work i saw this uh
you guys seen that prank where the
person bungee jumps like they jump
backwards
and then when they jump the instructor
or whatever it is
throws like a rope okay after he goes
wait wait wait he throws a rope out like
it's like it got disconnected the
person's like
oh what a horrible oh my god i don't
have a heart attack
just piss yourself on the way down how
do you react to that yeah actually
like you would have you fainted before
no dude did you guys did you guys see
the [ __ ] tick tock
where uh they're in an airplane and then
there's they're experiencing a lot of
turbulence to the point where
like you think they're gonna die like
like the guy's recording it and and you
just
see everyone like rocking spirit or
allegiant no i think that was the
caption
but like it's shaking and [ __ ] falling
all over the place
yeah i was like i don't think i'm gonna
be able to fly the same again there's a
guy on the plane like y'all better line
this thing now
he's like what's going on what happened
i landed right now
i gotta show it to you guys
[Laughter]
i've been in that situation that's why
it's funny but then also that guy's
reaction because like everyone's feeling
yeah because he's like what's going on
what's going on in here
oh [ __ ] chaos is pretty funny shaqiro
disasters are funny how do you guys do
with earthquakes because i love them
dude
didn't we just we just were kidding when
you said that no
i'll see it okay so just had one i know
we had a it was a pretty decent size one
too
in the middle of the night yes so i was
like whenever
i think earthquakes are fun all right so
if like rolling ones are interesting
though the ones that are like oh yeah so
like the other night i was in bed which
i literally was about to fall like about
to go to sleep and i felt it coming you
know you kind of feel it sometimes
yeah and i was like oh [ __ ] earthquake's
coming so i put my hand on her because i
know she's not used to it i was like
because i knew it was coming
all right so and then but then they
started shaking and as long as she's not
falling off the wall
then i'm like oh this shit's cool i'm
just like
and then i grab my phone like earthquake
because i think they're fun
what did she say she's just like what
the [ __ ]
is this you know babies yeah the baby's
like
what the what stop
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
you